[Applause]
[Music]
we have to be clear the world has never
been better than it is right now thanks
mostly to globalization there are less
and less Wars global poverty is falling
markedly and quality of life is
generally improving this is obviously
not happening in a uniform way across
all countries Berdych globally
everything is improving many Western
countries have decided to rebel and
refuse opener as well as understanding
among their nations in Europe for
example far-right parties are spreading
uncertainty those lepen in France that
vials of in the Netherlands where's
offer in Austria these are all good
examples of a new wave of politics that
is also affecting countries like Finland
Denmark Germany and Hungary among others
further it is also partly responsible
for the brexit victory in the United
Kingdom
[Music]
it is a movement that is taking
advantage of fear despite the fact that
we are living in societies that are
becoming safer and safer but as you well
know these ideas are not something that
is exclusive to Europe Donald Trump won
the US election and he has spoken about
his views which are clearly contrary to
globalization and immigration at this
point the best question we can ask is
are there any developed countries left
that still believe in open borders and
the globalization well the answer to
that question is yes there are and in
the video today we're going to be
looking at one of the most significant
of those countries cannabis open this
new year 2016 alone Canada admitted to
its country more than three hundred
thousand immigrants that is close to one
percent of Canada's total population
further this is a greater portion than
any other developed country and do note
is that this is nothing new this is
something that's been going on for two
decades the result of this is that today
one in every five Canadians was born
abroad this is a percentage that has
almost double that of the US and the UK
[Music]
and the fact of the matter is is that
this haven't led to any sort of national
tragedy in fact quite the opposite and
Canadians well loaded according to the
prestigious and veronik Institute's most
citizens almost 80% of them consider
immigration to be good for the economy
and think that it is one of the best
ways to deal with some of the issues
facing Canada such as its aging
population if you really think about it
it does make sense employment is the
country's most productive asset so why
would they want to prevent it from
growing in the context of a dynamic
economy what's the harm of immigrants
who are willing to work who are willing
to set up companies and want to get an
education it is something that we a
visual politic think is actually pretty
good with our first year in 2015
Justin Trudeau became Canada's prime
minister he defeated against all odds
the conservative Stephen Harper Harper
Hurd held the office for almost 10 years
since then the political agenda has been
dominated by a determination to deepen
the country's pro globalization policies
Trudeau himself a left winger has been
quite an advocate of promoting free
trade and social mobility in his first
year he signed a free trade agreement
with the European Union and confirmed
Canada's adherence to the TPP although
Trump's first action in office was to
destroy the TPP we're going to be the
biggest commercial agreement in history
in just a year Canada has built up free
trade agreements with nearly 60 percent
of the global economy further Trudeau
wants to expand this and increase trade
with China we've agreed to launch
exploratory talks towards a potential
free trade agreement between Canada and
China and the government is doing more
of the same concerning immigration
they've even set the goal of increasing
the number of immigrants they get by 50%
every single year from a refugee fleeing
somalia to becoming a member of
parliament in canada Amazonas once again
amid history of this week after he was
named the Canada's Minister of
immigrations by Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau in a major cabinet reshuffle
given these principles it probably
shouldn't surprise you to learn that
Canada is one of the countries that are
most committed
receiving Syrian refugees Canada has
received more than 33,000 Syrian
refugees since Trudeau took office in
his first year Trudeau himself went in
Toronto's airports to welcome the
refugees into the country I create
infallibly but hold on a second because
immigration to Canada isn't totally free
in fact it's not as free as we're visual
politic would like but what's really
important here is not whether or whether
there are not excessive administrative
difficulties but rather that citizens
shouldn't automatically view those who
are immigrating to the country as
criminals and this is precisely why
Canada is so successful they are a
country that takes pride in looking for
additional citizens they are not looking
for temporary immigrants since 1967
immigration to Canada has been based on
a point system this system considers
qualification experience professional
skills and the knowledge of either
French or English in the same way the
system also gives priority to those who
are needed by Canada's companies Canada
will lift the Mexican visa requirement
that has restricted travel to Canada
this move will make it easier for our
Mexican friends to visit Canada while
growing our local economies and
strengthening our communities the
tendency seems to be to make these
procedures easier but what is really
important is the social recognition and
the integration of immigrants into the
country
the Canadian Bill of Rights itself
recognizes the concept of multicultural
patrimony
there are followed policies to encourage
integration which by the way don't focus
on stripping the immigrants of their
original cultural identities but rather
see that as an enriching factor
[Music]
for example in Canadian schools it is
easy to find classes that are taught in
Spanish or Ukrainian and the results
support these policies indeed in the
last decade
Canada's growth has been bigger than the
u.s. the UK and Germany and its citizens
enjoy a very high standard of living now
hopefully it might be more clear as to
why Canada's immigration website
collapsed after Trump's victory the also
might understand why the Economist has
also had cover pages highlighting
Canada's living
now of course the Canadian model is not
perfect but compared to the new
nationalist and populist tendencies of
other countries Canada has shown what a
desirable alternative openness can
really be looking takeaway that we hope
this video really puts across is to try
and make things better in your country
rather than isolate it from the rest of
the world the latter of which is an
argument that many politicians like
Trump are defending well this is our
opinion here at visual politics and now
we would love to know yours do you think
immigration causes as many problems as
people claim we can like to live in a
culturally diverse country like Canada
let us know in the comments below also
if you enjoy this video please do give
it a like and also subscribe to our
Channel click on the icon on the screen
now for brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday and as always I'll see you
next time
[Music]